multiply and express as a simplified
rational state the domain so we'll start
with the domain the the only numbers
that will make this expression undefined
are the ones that would make the
denominator equal to zero and those are
the situation or that situation would
occur when either a be X or Y is equal
to zero if any of those are equal to
zero then we'll have we have an
undefined expression so we could say
that the domain the domain is all real
is B's X and Y's except except 0 or we
could be specific except except a b x
and y can't equal to 0 or you could
write maybe that maybe we write this
given that a B X and Y does not equal 0
that none of them can be equal 0 that's
these are just multiple ways of stating
the same thing now with that stated
let's actually multiply and simplify
this rational expression so what we have
is so when we multiply you just multiply
the numerators multiply the denominator
so you have 3x squared Y times 14 times
14 a squared B in the numerator and then
in the denominator in the denominator we
have 2 a B times times 18 X Y squared
and let's see where we can simplify this
thing well we can divide the 14 by 2 and
the 2 by 2 and see what we get 14
divided by 2 is 7 2 divided by 2 is 1
and if we could divide the 3 by 3 and
get 1 and divide the 18 by 3 and get 6
we do every time we divided the
numerator denominator by 2 now the
numerator is 1 and the denominator by 3
so we're not changing the expression and
then we can divide a squared divided by
a so you're just left with a you're just
left with an a in the numerator and a
divided by a is just 1 you have a B over
B those guys cancel each other out you
have an x squared divided by an X
so x squared divided by X is X and X
divided by X is just 2 1 so just becomes
an x over 1 or just an X and finally
have a Y over Y squared so if you divide
the numerator by Y you get 1 you divide
the denominator by Y you just get a Y so
what are we left with we are left with
in the numerator all we have these ones
we can ignore that doesn't really change
the number we have a 7 7 times a times X
that's what we have in the numerator and
in the denominator we just have a 6y 6y
and we have to add the constraint that
that a b x and y cannot equal 0 because
when you just look at this expression
right here you're like hey what's wrong
with X or I mean there isn't even any be
here so it's a little bit of a bizarre a
statement but there's your say hey why
can't X or ay be equal to zero over here
there it doesn't make it undefined but
in order for these to really be the same
expressions they have to have the same
domains or actually if you know if these
were functions that equal them in order
for that f of X to be equal to this f of
X right over here you'd have to
constrain the domain in a similar way so
it's not like this is fundamentally a
different expression if you allow X's
and A's in this one you can't allow X's
and A's for them to be really the same
you have to put the same constraints on
it